dieses fleisch konnte unsere ernährung
revolutionieren hühnerfleisch aus rein
pflanzlichen zutaten darüber fachsimpeln
profis aus der praxis mit den
entwicklern von der eth zürich 3 fleisch
genießer und ein vegetarier haben ein
start up unternehmen gegründet blendet
schicken
tatsächlich besteht ihr schicken nur aus
erbsen sonnenblumenöl und wasser wie ist
das möglich
erbsen öl und wasser uns die gleichen
nährstoffe bietet die werk brauchen um
unser fleisch sogar noch besser zu
machen mit mehr eiweiß mit
ballaststoffen damit es sogar noch
gesünder wird damit der zutaten bereit
später auch aussieht und schmeckt wie
hühnerfleisch werden die pflanzen
proteine durch hitze aufgefaltet die
kontrolle zeigt ohne bindemittel und
andere zusatzstoffe bildet sich die für
hühnerfleisch charakteristische
faserstruktur aus die faserstruktur ist
nötig fragen für den biss und das
mundgefühl dass man auch haupt wenn man
extrusion heißt das verfahren im eth
labor produzieren die jungen forscher
derzeit täglich 300 kilogramm von ihrem
pflanzlichen hühnerfleisch in dieser
maschine wird der brei erhitzt mit einer
schnecke gerieben durch ein engels
gekühltes ruhr gedrückt und verfestigt
das ergebnis plante schicken für den
endverbraucher
ständig entwickeln sie weiter testen und
kosten auch mit profiköchen wie rolf
hiltl früheren stadium kommen wir mit
august ihren mitbrüdern meine jungs sind
natürlich die absoluten profis in bezug
auf fasern und wie man das hinkriegt das
ist schon eine hohe schule aber wir
kommen dann als köchin köche beurteilen
ob das wirklich auch geht um
vorausschauend bei der zubereitung in
der pfanne wenn die hitze kommt und so
weiter wie verhält sich das produkt und
da kommt mir diverse ins geben noch
können sie nicht alle details preisgeben
doch in dieser halle im ehemaligen areal
des schweizer lebensmittel pioniers
julius maggi in winterthur wollen sie ab
nächstem frühjahr viel wie in einer
gläsernen fabrik produzieren ohne
geheime zusatzstoffe andere hersteller
von fleisch emiraten
das ist meiner meinung nach kein trend
das ist ein gesellschaftlicher wandel
und diesen wandel braucht auch dann wenn
wir zehn milliarden leute ernähren
wollen bis 2050 dann können wir nicht
weiterhin so viele viele tierische
proteine konsumieren wie wir es heute
tun
lukas und seine kollegen wollen keine
weltverbesserer sein sondern
alternativen bieten fleisch ohne
tierleid ab sommer 2020 auch in
deutschland
[Musik]